you're watching the daily climate show
coming up the chancellor announces a 25
tax on oil and gas profits but what does
this mean for investment in green energy
scotland plans to ban sales of the most
damaging single-use plastic items
and as monkey pox cases rise a warning
there could be more diseases spreading
from animals to humans without major
steps to protect wildlife and their
natural habitats
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our planet hear from the
leaders tasked with solving the problems
and explore solutions
now millions of people will welcome the
chancellor's announcement of a windfall
tax on the profits of oil and gas
companies and plans to use this levy to
help counter the rising cost of living
but some analysts are worried that rishi
sunak's plans will damage the investment
needed to build better energy security
and the uk's net zero ambitions so let's
hear what the chancellor had to say
companies will have a new and
significant incentive to reinvest their
profits
the new levy will be charged on profits
of oil and gas companies at a rate of 25
it will be temporary and when oil and
gas prices return to historically more
normal levels the levy will be phased
out with a sunset clause written into
the legislation
and crucially and crucially
with our new investment allowance
we are nearly doubling the overall
investment relief for oil and gas
companies
that means for every pound a company
invests
they'll get back 90
in tax relief
so the more a company invests the less
tax they will pay
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter joins us now from
westminster so hannah what impact will
this new step have on the fight against
climate change
i think amongst uh climate change
campaigners and various think tanks
there's broad satisfaction that
unearned unexpected profits of the oil
and gas industry are now being subject
to this windfall tax
there is also some consternation that if
you look closely at the detail actually
what the chancellor is doing here is
addressing a cost of living crisis
rather than the climate crisis
directly because the policy contains
real incentives to invest in uk
extraction not renewables and in their
view for campaigners this rather misses
an opportunity to kick-start
or accelerate even more investment in
the the the green energy transition and
also perhaps even misses opportunities
to invest in things like an insulation
program and so there there's real worry
about that that this was a missed
opportunity there was also separate
consternation about the chancellor
mentioning that he was considering
appropriate steps to further tax other
electricity generators who are enjoying
massive profits and that includes of
course not just the nuclear industry but
wind and solar too
i mean what are the oil and gas
companies saying about it
well they are predictably unhappy
shell has just released a statement
saying
we have consistently emphasized the
importance of a stable environment for
long-term investment and then has gone
on to outline plans to invest in a
low-carbon future and its plans to be a
part of the energy transition the not
very subtle inference there being if you
take money away from us all of that is
less is less assured but the industry
lobby group the offshore energies uk
lobby group has gone much further
calling the windfall tax a disappointing
and worrying development for a sector
that supports 200 000 uk jobs calling it
a backwards step that makes the uk seem
like an unpredictable place to do
business
but the bit that they've been really
pointed about is saying that there is
going to be a real impact on oil and gas
companies plans for investing in clean
energy mainly wind and a little bit of
solar and the the offshore energies uk
group saying that is actually
fundamentally going to make it much much
harder for the uk to hit its net zero
targets as a result
hannah thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and the sale of
plastic straws cutlery polystyrene cups
and food boxes will be banned in
scotland from the 1st of june the ban is
part of measures to clamp down on the
most environmentally damaging single-use
plastic items while reducing waste and
pollution the ban also covers all
single-use polystyrene food containers
and their lids as well as plastic
stirrers balloon sticks plates and
coffee stirrers
work has begun to turn
000 hectares of land in england into
nature recovery projects there are a
total of five projects across the peak
district the west midlands
cambridgeshire norfolk and somerset and
all aim to help tackle wildlife loss and
improve access to nature the projects
will share 2.4 million pounds in funding
from defra and natural england as part
of the government's target to halt the
decline in species abundance by 2030 and
protect 30 of english land by 2030.
[Applause]
a committee of mps is warning that
emissions must be reduced in the
construction of buildings if the uk is
to meet its net zero ambitions
their report states that 25 percent of
the country's total greenhouse gas
emissions can be attributed to the built
environment
but there is little government guidance
on how to reduce emissions from the
manufacture of materials through to
construction maintenance of buildings
and eventual demolition
[Applause]
now the number of monkey pox infections
around the world is continuing to rise
both wales and northern ireland have
confirmed their first cases today and
experts are warning we could see more
zoonotic diseases those transmitted from
animals to humans without better
regulation of the wildlife trade and
better care of natural habitats now more
than 250 cases of the virus have been
confirmed globally in the last three
weeks the uk has recorded the largest
number with 79 cases while spain has
confirmed 59 and portugal 39 cases
well joining us now to discuss this is
dr nigel seizer who's the executive
director of the research group
preventing pandemics at source and tell
us a little bit more about zoonotic
diseases these that transfer from
animals to humans are they on the rise
first of all
yes if you look over the last 50 years
we've seen a highly significant increase
in the number of new diseases
moving from wild wildlife into
humans diseases like sars nepa
ebola zika covid19 is one of these most
likely and and monkeybox which was first
detected about 40 years ago about 300
new diseases have been found in humans
in recent decades
so why is that happening what's the main
driver of this this rise in this kind of
transmission
so about 60 of these new diseases come
from wildlife they're what we call
zoonotic diseases and and this is
following from ever increasing
intensification of agriculture clearing
of forests especially in the tropical
regions uh increasing commercial
exploitation of wildlife more and more
people impinging on the natural world
towns and cities in tropical forest
areas
the use of wildlife
the exotic animal trade and
intensification of animal agriculture
farming of cattle pigs and poultry has
also contributed to this risk so how do
we go about stopping it
well the key thing is to greatly
increase efforts to protect tropical
forests to to regulate strictly enforce
close down some of the wildlife trade
and commercial use of wildlife including
things like some of the exotic pet trade
coming into europe and the united states
as well as what people might have seen
more in the news which is the live
animal markets in places like china
parts of africa and latin america and so
on all these things contribute to risk
and another really key area is doing a
much better job to address how we treat
and take care of of livestock pigs and
poultry in particular
and very briefly you mentioned covert
there has that helped focus minds do you
think that could help prompt change the
fact that the world has suffered this
pandemic
well we've been working intensively on
this throughout the kovit 19 pandemic
and i have to say we're actually very
disappointed to see that most
governments are not giving much more
attention to the to the actual origins
of these diseases i mean the good news
is that the things we need to do
to address climate change are also some
of the things that would reduce the risk
of future pandemics like better
protecting tropical forests other things
as well like taking better care of
wildlife addressing risks in the live
animal trade and improving the
regulation and controls around
intensification of animal agriculture
these are all things that we should be
doing anyway and covid19 and now
monkeypox to some extent as well remind
us that much more effort is needed in
these areas
dr nigel sizer very interesting to talk
to you thanks very much indeed
thank you
well that's it for me thank you for
watching see you next time
[Music]
you